the museum is submitting proposals to
several foundations in the hope
to gain funds to build a tropical
butterfly conservatory so we have an
either an error and up here we have no
error
so the part that as you can tell even
when i read it i had a little bit of
trouble with is when we read in the hope
to gain normally when you're talking
about hope you would say in
the
hope
of
of whatever your you know whatever the
hope is part of so in this case in the
hope of gaining
in the hope of gaining funds you
wouldn't really say in the hope to gain
funds so this one i would change to in
the hope of
gaining
funds let me write that a little bit
neater in the hope of
gaining funds to the to build a tropical
butterfly conservatory so the error i'd
put the error here in second d right
over here in the hope
to gain in now you're in the hope of
something not in the hope to something